Welcome back everyoneit's Charlie
this will be my full Star Wars Andor
episode 11 video there are a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet we'll start at the beginning work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments as we go along starting with the
episode titled daughter of pharynx it's meant to
be a reference to andor's mother because she dies
before the events of the episode like she's dead
at the beginning of the episode the daughters of
ferrics are basically what they call the female
members of their Community who are like Auntie
Empire like just to distinguish them from the
other Imperial people that are living there kind
of taking over the town the planet so to speak
like when his friend tells B2-EMO the Droid that
the daughters of ferrix need his help on a very
important matter all the female friends there
that are taking care of the arrangements for her
body need his help the actual opening scene is
of Andor and melshi still trying to escape from
narkina 5 the Imperials looking to track them
down all the other escapees they don't know how
many people made it off but later in the episode
they say not enough of us made it out because
some of them probably did die in the attempt
but the big idea is that a lot of the people
that did wind up escaping will wind up joining the
Rebellion will probably see them during season two
maybe not literally all the actors but just the
idea that some of them will eventually become a
bigger part of the Rebellion we did learn a little
bit more about what's going on with their plans
for season two and how they're going to handle
the story because there's going to be some time
jumps leading up to the events of Rogue one I'll
talk about that later in the video the way they
explain andor's mother's death is she's been in
declining health for a long time and she's stopped
taking her meds so she started to get worse even
faster and a lot of these scenes on ferrics are
just meant to set up the finale because like next
week is literally the finale so the major forces
between the rebels and the Empire are converging
on ferrix for the funeral on the side of the
rebels cinta is still there watching for Andor
she's gotten a job working at the bar nearby so
she can just stay close and keep an eye on him
this guy who's also been staying there is part
of the Empire like you see him in uniform here
while they're interrogating Biggs he's basically
doing the exact same thing but for for the Empire
waiting to see when Andor comes back so they can
try and use him to find Luthen even though they
think that they're looking for someone else then
they have more of a comedic scene about Andor and
melshi escaping the planet and the basic message
here is they probably should have been nicer and
just asked the aliens for help and they would
have had way less trouble we see some of the local
narcanians I believe this is the first time that
they've appeared in Star Wars I couldn't tell if
the voices were done by guest actors because I
didn't see any in the credits but if you think
there were any sly Cameo scenes playing these
roles let me know in the comments the whole thing
with an Arcania is that they had planned to turn
them in and collect the reward money but they form
a common bond in their shared hatred of the Empire
because the narcanians hate the Empire who have
been poisoning their water supply killing off the
Aquatic Life their food source and obviously
and or Moshi hate them because they're doing
terrible things to them and it's just another
callback to the formation of the Rebellion like
this hodgepodge group of people from all different
planets cultures coming together because they've
all been wrong by the empire in some big way we
learn about dedra's plan to set a trap for Andor
because she wants to interrogate him she doesn't
really care that much about Andor she wants to use
him to get to Luthen but she doesn't actually know
who Luthen is or his name she's just using the
name axis to refer to him because he's the axis of
all Rebel activity across the Galaxy the two days
that they referenced for this to take place is
basically the rest of season one like the end of
the second day will be the end of the finale in it
just to let you know that the big center of action
in the finale that this big final battle before
season two will happen on ferrix it all goes down
on ferrix they explain the local custom is to mix
the ashes of the dead with mortar and stone dust
literally turning the people into bricks and using
them to either build or repair walls around the
city so you literally become part of the city but
here's what I actually think is going on I think
what they're foreshadowing because later in the
episode when they talk about creating the brick
from andor's mother they say what they're gonna
do with the brick is find a wall for it I think
the wall is actually a metaphor for the empire in
the finale like someone is going to live literally
fire the brick at the Imperials in the finale to
help them escape and metaphorically it'll be like
his mother sticking it to the Empire one last time
even though she's dead back at Luthen's Shop kleya
cleans another artifact for sale vel sartha comes
to let them know about the funeral on ferrix and
the Empire still being very active potentially
being a big problem for them because they wanted
to get rid of Andor and of Anders caught by the
Empire it's bad news for everybody remember kleya
was the one that tasked vel sartha and cinta with
killing and or even though vel sartha doesn't want
to do it she doesn't want to kill Andor they tease
some tension between the two of them too it just
sounds like clay isn't super popular within their
Network just because she's so hardcore they move
the Jedi Temple Guardian helmet which is now
sitting right next to padme's helmet from the
prequels the Jedi Temple Guardians were the ones
that were guarding literally the Jedi Temple on
Coruscant the grand Inquisitor actually used to
be a Jedi Temple Guardian on Coruscant before he
joined the inquisitorious I don't know if it's
his armor specifically it could be most of the
other artifacts and Easter eggs have already
talked about but one of the other biggest most
important Easter eggs I think is when they're
standing against the wall here next to these
Stone pieces the stone pieces are from the mortise
Gods mural in Star Wars Rebels the mural of the
Father the Son and the daughter then there's this
whole subplot in the episode about the b2e mode
Droid dealing with the death of andor's mother and
taking it really hard being lonely afraid to be
alone trying to get his friend to stay the night
at the place acting sentimental in a human way
that you wouldn't expect a Droid to do I believe
they're actually already selling it as merchandise
I think they were showing it off at Comic-Con
earlier this year too we check in with Bix we
see the toll that the torture has taken on her
she's barely hanging on like she's kind of a wisp
kind of floating around barely staying conscious
they keep questioning her about the rebels and we
find out they mistakenly think that Anto Kreegyr
the person who they're trying to lay the trap for
on stearguard is actually Luthen which they might
wind up using to their benefit that's potentially
a huge win for Luthen because now he's on the
radar or at least his ship is on their radar
at least the way they're explaining it the Empire
will catch into kringer and his men and kill them
so if Luther leans into the curve and allows them
to continue thinking that it was Anto Kreegyr who
was behind everything then they'll be way less
heat on him heading into season two back in mon
mothma's we learned that her daughter is engaged
in this really ancient ritual this cultural
practice that mon mothma in vel sartha absolutely
hate it's meant to be part of some ancient
tradition that the more modern members of their
society the more Progressive ones have tried to
get rid of her daughter being super hardcore about
it might just be like a little bit of rebellion
like oh if you hate it mother then that means
that I'm going to love it like the rebellious
teenager phase but I think part of that storyline
is meant to be a parallel for what happened with
some of the children who eventually became part
of the first order causing the Empire to basically
come back in a new form kind of like in real
life the alt-right espousing believes that the
Nazis might have believed in during World War II
era despite the fact that everyone in present-day
agreeing that Nazis are terrible and everything
that they stood for and believed is terrible so
she's worried that her daughter will be condemned
to the same fate that she was was condemned to to
continue following these practices vel sartha
getting worried about the marriage proposals in
mon mothma agreeing to get that loan it's just
another example of antiquated Customs that both
of them hate just tied to what her daughter
is practicing right now her talking about the
missing credits that she's trying to replace being
at wits and thinking that it's all gone tits up
for her like oh it's over they're gonna find out
about what's going on and Luthen not completely
knowing what's going on is probably just to set up
vel sartha going rogue and using some of the money
that they stole the funds from aldani to help mon
mothma out lately they're just trying to show you
how that winds up happening in practice like vel
sartha will be the one to try and get the funds
to help her out because it's only 400,000 credits
and they stole 80 million credits and because of
that mon mothma won't be forced to betroth her
daughter to this lone shark's son still kind of
wondering what winds up happening to her daughter
because she's not referenced during Rogue one at
all or during the original trilogy and just
briefly in like some Legends Canon I think
I think that's where her daughter comes from it's
from the Legends Canon also her name Leida sounds
so much like Princess Leia that it just feels like
Princess Leia will become her surrogate daughter
because something terrible winds up happening to
her real daughter syril karn gets a call from his
former sergeant from the first couple of episodes
who informs him about what's happening on ferrix
with andor's mother's funeral and or might show
up obviously giving him the push to come back
to fairies to try and catch him himself probably
getting fired from his job in the process too like
oh you cut off from work to go try and catch this
person that you weren't authorized to definitely
getting fired I've already made all the jokes
about syril karn's character he's like the most
put upon character in the Star Wars Universe right
now he's like the Star Wars equivalent of Meg The
Whipping Boy the one that everybody loves to make
fun of I think the whole tragedy of his character
is that he believes so strongly in the Empire
this institution but the Empire doesn't care
about him at all and will probably ultimately let
him down and that will wind up crushing his soul
like the thing that he worshiped failing him
utterly also kind of wondering what the future
of his relationship with Dedra is going to be
like will she just continue keeping be an eye
on him or will he eventually work with the ISB it
just feels like there's something weird between
those characters Luthen goes back to visit saw
gerrera who calls him on letting kreegyr die for
their cause they did that in previous episode
too like are you prepared to let this person
die just to help our Rebellion continue and he
was obviously collateral damage they want to
make it seem like Luthen is doing things that
are just as despicable as the Empire but even
though saw gerrera hates the idea on the grounds
of morality he makes peace with it because they
are at War this is a war and he is probably one of
the most militant people inside the Rebellion he's
one of those characters that will do anything it
takes to defeat the Empire Luthen and Kleya have
that funny conversation about Andor using the
code talking about what's happening on ferrix
to make it sound like they're talking about a
bidding war over artifacts and or is the piece
that Luthen says they need or the whole thing will
go tits up for them the other collector that they
reference is the Empire we don't want to lose
our piece to the other collector because there's
a good chance that could kill the Rebellion this
is actually a cool story behind this new Imperial
ship that show shows up to stop him from leaving
this is called an imperial Arrestor Cruiser all
the dishes on it are powerful tractor beams
capable of stopping even very large Capital
ships from jumping to hyperspace its design is
actually based from original concept art from
the first Star Wars A New Hope movie George
Lucas elected not to use it and they just put
it in the archives but when they were making
solo a Star Wars story a couple years ago the
designers went into the archives found this and
just repurpose it is a brand new ship they do
that all the time in the new Star Wars stuff they
did the same thing during the Mandalorian season
2 with this tank is actually based on original
concept art from Empire Strikes Back when he
uses the Alderaan transponder code to mask's true
identity it's another Sly reference to Bale Organa
and his role in the formation of the Rebellion on
Alderaan he was one of the main Leaders with Mon
mothma and a lot of their resources the money
the weapons the ships came from him or because
of him we didn't see him during season one I'm
not expecting him in the finale there might be
a cameos in the finale but I think that we'll see
him during season two also the whole scene of him
faking the transplant founder code is meant to be
similar to The Return of the Jedi scene where they
do the exact same thing to get past the Imperial
blockade to Endor do they have a code clearance
it's an older coaster but it checks out I was
about to clear them really like the Escape scene
turns out his ship has a whole bunch of surprise
weapons defense systems makes sense him using it
for so much spycraft but now the whole idea
is that the Empire has a record of his ship
so even though he himself Luthen the person isn't
on their radar his ship is and they'll be watching
for that like I said the opportunity for him is
impending it on Anto Krieger because we already
know that he's going to be captured and killed
so if Luthen can just make them think that it
was all Anto Kreegyr and he was really Anto
Kreegyr that escaped then it'll mean way less
heat for him from the Empire heading into season
two it'll be much easier for him to get around
then Andor learns about his mother's death when
he calls to check on her from his friend of the
port kind of breaking him a little and pushing him
further towards the Rebellion like the whole idea
is that he was stuck in prison because of what
the empire did and wasn't able to see his mother
before she died the only upside there is that
had he gone back sooner he probably would have
been captured and it all been over melshi's whole
conversation with him about splitting up some they
can tell someone about what the Empire has been
doing we need to tell somebody about this they
need to know is actually more of a season two
teaser and obviously for the formation of the
formal Rebellion right now there's still just
like a bunch of disparate cells all over the
Galaxy season two they actually said that they're
going to be heading to Yavin 4 in the traditional
rebel base when you think of the rebels I believe
there'll be a couple years time Jump throughout
season two because they're going to cover a
couple years time within the Canon injury that
we'll see the larger Rebellion come together on
Yavin 4. and if you didn't recognize him melshi
is in Rogue one like he's part of the Rebellion so
he'll be back in season two as part of that so the
whole idea here though is that part of andor's
Ark in season one is him going from not caring
about the rebels or the Empire to finally caring
about what's actually going on around him because
of all the stuff that he's been through with the
Empire especially lately at the prison he is much
more Pro Rebellion before it was really just about
the money he really only cared about finding his
sister and obviously that's still a big plot
thread they haven't addressed yet actually
answering the question about who his sister is
and what happened to her because the finale is
next week I think that they'll at least give us a
hint or some kind of reveal about what's going on
with his sister you can post all your theories in
the comments below about that my episode 12 finale
video will post next week after they release
it they've already confirmed that season two
is going to start filming this month so it'll
probably take them till early 2024 to finish
all the episodes and release it we also already
have four Star Wars series that we're going to
be releasing 2023 next year the Mandalorian season
3 episode start in February then the Ahsoka series
after that the bad batch episodes and then at
the end of the year they're supposed to release
the high Republic acolyte Series so next year
is going to be a big year for Star Wars really
really excited for the Mandalorian season 3 in
the Ahsoka series I think it's going to be really
really good if there are any big Easter eggs or
references that you spotted in the episode that
I didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments everyone click here for my
black panther wakanda forever post credit scene
video and click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!